we closed this week with a second look
at the most important news story of the
past year perhaps of a generation the
introduction of performance-enhancing
drugs into camel beauty contests or this
week we brought you the news that 12
camels were disqualified at a Saudi
camel pageant after they were found to
have used Botox but even without
cheating how do you judge a camel
pageant patty McHugh is a camel herder a
camel trader and all-around dromedary
expert he joins us tonight mister is
cute thank you very much for joining us
have you ever seen this kind of doping
in the camel community okay
it's a bit of an unusual story that's
for sure to have Botox putting their
lips in their head to make them look
nicer but it's not unusual I suppose
there's big money big prestige and you
know thousands and thousands of camels
these advance everybody wants to win and
whatever it takes us suppose yes and
look I just want to be clear up front
given the environment in this country
I'm not objectifying camels at all I
mean I appreciate camels for who they
are not just how they look but how do
you tell the difference between an
attractive camel and let's just say a
less attractive camel beauty is in the
eye of the beholder they have certain
guidelines at these competitions where
it's configuration you know how there
are years of prick'd have their lips
drop down and one of the main things in
these competitions is here they'll it
drops down their bottom lip so I'd
imagine that's where the Botox has been
put if anywhere at all to make that lip
look for and nice right I mean it's
really just a group of people get
together and say this is the criteria
and this is what we're going to do it's
a bit of a way of life I suppose for
them over there is it is a droopy camel
lip preferable to a taut camel lip well
competition rules I would imagine that's
one of the things they look for they
also look for different things like that
becomes and these pricked up and
everybody looking happy you know but
certainly the big droopy blip is pretty
good I mean Annika there's a photo there
of her I think it's a five million
dollar black Saudi camel that's just
magnificent and it's got the biggest
droopier slip on the planet you know
it's quite amazing
it's a beautiful camel do camels know
when you're looking at their humps can
they sense it did I love sorry when you
looking at their humps yeah do they know
do they I mean do they feel
uncomfortable if they feel like you're
staring at their humps okay I think we
may have lost our connection to mr.
McHugh who should we should note once
more is one of the world's pre-eminent
experts on camels of all kind single
hump camels double hump camels we should
also say that though we're making light
of this story this is not a small thing
in the 70 Kingdom where beauty pageants
featuring people are less common but
these are a very big deal mr. McKee we
have you back I believe that connection
has been restored can you just describe
very quickly we're almost out of time
but the best-looking camel you've ever
seen the best-looking came along means
that we've got something new this is
wild camels in Australia they truly
remarkable being filthy great-looking
animals except we don't have Beauty
competitions work like they do in the
Middle East they have you know 20,000
cancel turn up for a beauty competition
but we could certainly hold their own in
Australia with our wild camels it's how
much you can now Australia always holds
it same mr. McHugh thank you for joining
us I appreciate that